the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so the first thing we're going to do is
a power module and it's important that
when you're trying to get draw power
from any source even a battery or
anything like that that you try to match
or you want to Matt draw the maximum
amount of power you need to have the
right load on it so we're going to try
to figure out experimentally what the
right load is for this solar panel and
the way you do that is you you hook up a
resistor or a potentiometer to a in a
closed circuit around this and first to
measure the resistance of it then you
hook a hook this up in a closed circuit
and measure the voltage drop across it
and you can calculate power from a V
squared over R and so you just do that
for a bunch of different resistances
just changing this and you should be
able to get a graph that goes up and
then down and if your graph power versus
resistance and based off of that you can
figure out what the appropriate load to
place on it is and still generate a
power curve for that again make sure you
don't measure the resistance when it's
hooked up because you're going to fry
the voltmeter and then the second thing
we're going to have you do is optimize
the angle so you want to put the solar
panel at different angles both in this
direction and in this direction and
measure for a variety of angles what the
power output it is and so for that you
can just have choose a resistance with
the potentiometer and then measure
voltage and get power that way and then
I have protractor somewhere yeah or
what close enough yeah and so you can
use that to measure the angle of the
solar panel and when you're doing this I
want you to take for the two for the
angle ones and the shading once I want
you to take at least 10 data points and
for the voltage one I want you to take
at least 15 data points for different
resistances empowers and then the last
thing we're going to look at is how
shading the solar panel affects the
energy being outputted by it and in this
case I want you to if you look at these
solar panels each of these long things
is an individual cell and they're wired
in series so I want you to shade the
solar panel going down this way and then
going across this way and just measure
the surface area of the exposed solar
panel and then food for that one just
choose the angle that you like and
choose a resistance that you like and
then measure power being outputted by
that
and as you can see it's kind of annoying
to attach wires to other wires in the
developing world especially if you don't
have solder in techniques or anything
like that easily available so there are
a lot of different ways of attaching
them together a lot of times you the way
you'll see people wire things it's just
taking two wires and twisting them
together and I neither works as a short
term solution but you'll see entire
system's rigged up that way and yeah
it's not particularly good
so you are you're comfortable
calculating power given this we just do
this right over our 19
we're not i'm not going seven yeah right
so go to Twitter go about 20 yeah it's
gonna
they saw our panel outputs 15 watts and
most of like the tiny resistors you see
are rated for underwater have one so if
you hook them up to this they were just
thrown out or get like super hot burning
so this one's rated for nothing like
point where point for ya and so change
your angle relative to Point into the
Sun would that make sense you be like
yes you just like your son is there then
like kind of tilt your panel here and an
angle towards the Sun like kind of like
that that make sense like the Sun is
there
understand accord and I want to really
battery out of the way too because I
think it might officiating so we're
gonna use it kind of our thang sounds
really yeah
can you move it
the manger scenes
okay and so now we flip it 90 degrees
and then do the exact same thing a
figure on political metric say it's 95
Oh
this lab is just for fun so I gave
people the option of either making
something cool if you're feeling
creative or just doing each operation
with no intent other than learning the
operation if you're not feeling creative
it's up to you so some people made
really cool stuff and some people just
have fun and anything is fine thing so
we're going to go through a bunch of
things so one is drilling holes and
sheet metal and you also want to cut pc
pipe and if you you could cut this on
the bandsaw but it's probably going to
be a little and even and this is
actually faster and really successful so
what you do with this PVC cutter is you
just open it all the way up and then
just tonight you really quickly cut a
ring very handy you couldn't use that
tool on metal unfortunately so we have
this tool for cutting pipe this is the
sharp bit and these are just bearings
that allow the pipe to spin around and
around so what you do is you open it up
you load the copper in you tighten it
and then you spin it around a few times
tight Nets band tight and spend the more
times you tighten and spin then the
cleaner edge you'll get if you really
just use a lot of course of course it'll
work but it'll be ugly so this is copper
which is expensive and we don't have
that much so this is the one area where
you need to just cut a little ring don't
cut after yourself we also are going to
cut rebar so the hacksaw is ready here
for cutting leave our well you could
just hold the rebar in one hand and use
the hex on the other it's going to be
really miserable and your possible to do
successfully so we have advice so you
can load the rebar in and then cut so
you too long maybe there's a bigger
fight
Oh